[Music]
i know me too
a former fox host
who says santa claus is white
no
he's got to be white isn't he german no
he's an eskimo oh yeah class yeah that's
german right saint nick
nicholas class yeah i'm pretty sure he's
german yeah he's probably white then no
he's german yeah nicolas this good shot
he's white saint nick yeah is it wait
claw's the last name is it nicholas
claus claus isn't he an elf
no he's not what i do know is when i see
an asian sound that doesn't look right
to me yeah do you spit on them santa's
huh asian santas
or something oh they just look like
monks dude fat monks with a beard santa
claus is a mascot right like that's all
he is well the real santa though they're
talking about the real santa not the not
the mascots at the at the mall not the
vietnamese ones
hey don't be hating on malls all right
so former fox host who said santa claus
is white calls
colin kaepernick a racist
anybody hear about calling cabernet
recently no what do you do came out with
the documentary or something about
kneeling
no it's about like how he's tr i didn't
watch dogma but i think it's supposed to
be like equating nfl to slavery the
combine so so actually the document is
not fully about that no because i've
heard that reference but that's the joke
though right like oh no i've heard
that's a real reference because it is a
little weird it's hella weird like you
bench press and all that okay okay and
then they they like have you strip down
and just stand yeah they do that's a
little weird like the tom brady photo
have you seen it no but it's probably
funny this picture yeah
why would it do come up your dick and go
take as much look at those they might
grab your butt muscles they make you
grab your balls and bull bend over and
cough like the jails okay that's prison
yeah i don't think they're worried about
your coke addiction as long as you throw
a ball so so that context he he dropped
a doc uh it's actually not a documentary
it's a fiction that is on netflix uh i
think it's something about calling black
or white or something like that
it's more about him and his story in
general and it's directed by ava
duvernay from turlock you know turlock
no anyone know turlock
it's like uh near like modesto you know
modesto yeah yeah oh yeah yeah that's
where he's from oh okay from there okay
yeah so eva duvernay farm town amazing
amazing director uh they put together
this i have a duverney bruh avid duverny
there it is
thank you uncultured swan
thank you swine i haven't called that in
a
while um
they they put out this uh i guess this
film about him and just things in
general that do involve obviously be
social stigma and racism in the current
world and stuff but it's the first
uh opening intro of the entire thing
that is the most talked about thing so
what you're referencing is this moment
where he first talks about how
everybody wants to be you know anybody
who wants to go into football blah blah
like i love the game when i was a kid
and i wanted blah blah right but
everybody knows if you want to be in the
nfl if you want to go into a be real
athlete you got to go through the
combine first and then they show these
uh very very you know uh they got all
these like you know black actors that
come in and pretend to be you know uh at
the combine they're being tested and
different things like that he's talking
about how coaches come in and they want
you to be an animal they want you to be
a savage they want you to what's this
point though
about this moment or about the whole
thing just about the combine and like
because all i've heard is just to tie in
that with the slave rules i don't know
his point so what happens so what
happens is these guys and non and
non-white and black guys in the nfl too
and i guess
the the reason why people were talking
about is just because of this first part
though that everybody's freaking out
about and remembering because it's
mainly just black people that come in
and show that they're athletes or
whatever and it's all like uh white
coaches and stuff like that that are
like test the white athletes don't go
through the combat he's not showing that
in this this opening part of the
documentary also what it reminds people
that just the imagery is it looks like
it's not a reminder it's it's it's
like depiction let me just finish the
context and you'll understand
[ __ ] okay so from there all
right he's talking about what the
combine is how people get tested and
then the imagery goes from them walking
off the screen passing him and then it
goes into like back that is slavery so
it's the same thing good transition then
it transitions while he's still there
giving kind of this like narrative or
this monologue in the beginning and then
it shows imagery where like
like like we're talking about how
they're like stripped down and stuff
like that there's slaves being auctioned
off being kind of measured for like how
useful they might be and then he brings
in mirrored uh imagery or parallel
imagery in the nfl combine where they're
also standing there getting their
wingspan measured they're jumping and
stuff like that and then he talks about
how when you first get tested in the
combine and the way they're talking
about you and the way that they want you
to do certain things he says what's
really happening there is the fact that
there's kind of like um they're teaching
you uh or grooming you about the concept
of like the power
um dynamic within there and who's in
control and that's kind of how he's
pitching it so that's the first opening
scene even though the entirety that's
controversial as [ __ ] exactly i don't
know uh that take is a little bit but
that's been a long-term conversation
especially in the nba which is
predominantly black the nfl is still
probably majority block maybe not
predominantly um
it is easily yeah and then don't quote
me um but i'm pretty sure we need more
diversity let's get some asian
basketball players you got jeremy dude
yeah
but uh but we need more tall asians the
other thing isn't uh always coaches
because especially the nfl and nba there
are more black coaches but they're the
owners it's the owners i don't know if
there's a majority owner in american
sports that's black i might be wrong
don't quote me but i don't think so
that's the big argument yeah because
we're talking like billionaires versus
millionaires versus whatever right
they're like well lebron james makes a
hundred million you're like yeah the
dude who's you know in this argument is
puppeteering him is worth billions of
dollars so where is that so are they
trying to blame where the how the owners
got there like i guess i'm trying to
figure out what the point is the power
dynamic the power dynamic between a
bunch of like really power dynamics
how we arrived here i mean we get to
control the future right so in the
future
if now we have all these athletes if
they want to become the owners and like
i don't know change the system we can
well i think that that's why i think
billionaires don't want to own sports
teams i think billionaires
jay-z's like a lot of musicians i don't
know if he's a majority owner oh okay
sam same with like magic johnson
do you know what a team costs that [ __ ]
oh yeah multi-billion dollars yeah
multi-billion so jay-z is worth a
billion he can't be a majority owner of
a three billion dollar team right yeah
even if he spent all his work he could
easily do it but but but he owns the tar
heels right the uh no he owns uh bobcats
yeah they're only the bobcats oh yeah
charlotte hornets right he always but
not even i don't think he's majority
either i don't think he's majority yeah
and that's jordan yeah but but i think
no no magic johnson's also not a
majority he's a one-person owner yeah
he's trying to shack only part
oh cool is it like a race thing or is it
more like who can actually afford it is
so
upper echelon like rich [ __ ]
as objective as just like ownership in
the space i think it's talking about the
power dynamic uh that involves like
the theme of racism in general so for
example this is also coming from a guy
who pretty much quote unquote got
blackballed by the entire you know
league
for doing something and and so it's more
about like the theme of suppression is
he trying to draw core because to me the
way i'm seeing it it's like
it maybe i don't understand but it feels
like he's drawing he's just pulling
parallels
but he's almost tying his own
conclusions
and then also trying to imply something
is fishy
but that i don't quite follow the line
fishy but i think it's kind of like the
uh uh
like a quality of star like they
obviously got a late start in american
wealth and success i i think he is also
trying to directly imply a particular
thing because remember he was subdued in
a sense right he specifically for who he
was and what he was quote-unquote trying
to kneel for
was like uh rejected from the entirety
of like that he got they didn't give him
a chance with that yeah you've never
heard the modern day slavery argument
like modern day slavery is often tied to
that
even music i think for a long time was
tied to that too like oh all these like
more in the 90s it's a little different
now but like oh still tied to it yeah
yeah like all the artists are black and
then like all the producers and uh
people that own it yeah our our lawyer
actually um fought for a lot of [ __ ]
up contracts that like for example sly
in a family stone master p all these
music
artists who were exploited back in the
days um well not master people he's he's
his lawyer but like but like yeah in the
70s 80s and on like you know they would
take people from poor communities that
were just like i want a record deal
and then they would exploit them right
so then he would go back and then get
royalties get money and all that stuff
so like um
it does happen and that that that makes
sense where people get exploited but the
term slavery is pretty strong like we've
been on the receiving end of some pretty
shitty contracts too right but we're
still
voluntarily signing two terms for sure
right that's why it's called modern day
slavery yeah but still it's still strong
to include that it's like a modern day
holocaust it's like it's pretty strong
but if he says like modern day kind of
got the [ __ ] and it doesn't have any
punch you're not making a documentary
what i'm saying is like that fishiness
is he does it feel like it's turning up
the dials of fishiness especially if
you've benefited in the multi-millions
you know taking the term slavery and
then saying but then also living in a
mansion at the same time you know it's
just i don't know it just feels i think
you can make money off something and
then complain about it still yeah right
because it's relative right and you
probably know more about it because you
were in it than like then before you
were in it you know what i mean and and
i don't know if you use the actual term
slavery i think it was like artistic
imagery and parallelism that like really
kind of like i don't agree or disagree
i'm just trying to explore the idea of
what's going on to me it seems like
whistleblowing because without this i
wouldn't have known like how much teams
cost and who's involved and all this
stuff it's a pretty common topic i think
nflpa
versus the nfl is a constant thing and
what's the nflpa nflp is an nfl players
association
constant battle between them and the nfl
because the nfl wants more games which
means more injuries a lot of the time
shorter careers less money less money
that's in both
nfl and nba and nfl contracts aren't
like mlb contracts where people are
secure like if you get [ __ ] up you're
done yeah and they're everyone's getting
[ __ ] up in that yeah they got quote
better right because they just gave a
little bit every time they give a little
bit more a little bit more a little bit
more but like you know the junior sales
out there like the guys who killed
themselves with cte maybe or that too
right so there's an argument to be made
for like you know having more players
rights or more of a player's say against
the owners who seem to dominate the
conversation massively yeah better
retirement programs because these guys
there's no retirement yeah and again
again coming from a dude like kaepernick
who is he and his former teammate eric
reid uh reached a settlement with the
nfl for less than 10 million after
alleging the team owners colluded to
keep them out of league as punishment
for their protest so it's like they're
also experiencing a really really unique
power dynamic and struggle
like regardless of the analogy to the
nfl combine and like the idea of slavery
and stuff so i could only imagine the
amplification of like what
that's that feeling or that theme or
that parallel can can be like especially
after the fact right so
i mean it's arguable always because
people do sign up to go to the nfl
people kids are usually wanting to just
do this because they love the game they
dream about it yeah well because they
have such point of privilege as like
football players or nba players like the
narrative is always like shut up and
dribble shut up and do whatever yeah
show up and throw a pick
that's what i say
until like the narrative kind of
benefits them a little bit you know so
it is kind of interesting to see how
people react i mean like well let's
something similar that i can see the
parallel in is like like britney spears
right we're like yeah she's
a celebrity she's doing great whatever
but if those allegations are true about
how her dad is exploiting the [ __ ] out
of her and all this it's still an unfair
kind of quote unquote modern day slavery
situation right so like
it is good that they're shining a light
on these kind of things but then like i
don't know enough to actually like make
a decision on on this [ __ ] and see if
it's bad or good
he made money off of it he should shut
up
but that's what people want to hear
right people say that's true who they
were they telling kobe shut up and
dribble or who was it they tell that to
lebron i don't have an opinion shut up
and dribble we just want to play we want
to watch you play this yeah
unless the the topic
benefits the owners and then they want
them to speak up and to just give a
little bit more on to the story of like
why this things like this actually do
stir stuff is because this uh former fox
news host megyn kelly who was infamously
declared santa who declared santa claus
white i don't know that's funny yeah
what's that have to do with that i have
no idea he is white right it's literally
german and also i guess you hear her
like making it a racial thing
point is she freaked out over the former
nfl star uh and his comments on racism
and she says she fox news you said yeah
a former now she's on camera nick he's
insane
uh this is a racist guy he really is a
racist guy and he hates our country he
hates america it's just another day that
sounds like some fox news journalist
that's a hot take it's just another day
that netflix gives this guy his own
special and i'm like well i guess it's
going to be about how racist america is
turns out it's how racist colin
kaepernick is
so i mean like based a little bit based
though she's got to touch this lady so i
guess the point is it does stir up
conversation and it's not it's not meant
to necessarily have everybody be like
this is the decision this is how things
should be but i think uh maybe they did
a good job at least having people have a
conversation have have they ever
expressed what the ideal scenario is
the players association it's a constant
battle because the nfl has so much power
like you're talking about billions and
billions and billions of dollars and
even roger goodell he works for all the
owners he's there at the pleasure of the
owners
so
it's really centralized as [ __ ] like the
players have a say now but they didn't
always have one yeah but it's barely
anything but it's a negotiation i don't
even know if they have a say it's
negotiations
smith he's the head of the nflpa he
constantly gets railroaded by the nfl
like especially when it comes to
retirement benefits all kinds of stuff
they do have some of that now but it's
not great and players complain about it
all the time and they should they're
getting the [ __ ] out of the stick at the
end for sure well the average nfl career
is three years max right and so you're
talking about with a lifetime of cte and
think about the guys that don't even
make it to nfl like in pursuit to the
average age of an nfl player is like in
the 50s i think because you you just get
a long long time career no no when they
die when they die
life expectancy yeah wow because of what
they do to their bodies some of them are
big guys and then cte and then crazy man
isn't it like um also the amount of
athletes that get picked is really
small compared to the other sports too i
mean yeah yes but this is baseball just
also because baseball's farm teams just
for more context too because the nfl can
be so lucrative and it really is some
people's only shot or else they have to
go work at a car dealership or something
there are guys who will stand outside of
every stadium
like around the time that they're
getting teams together and stuff with
signs saying like hey
like i can play i can throw i can catch
i can do whatever and they'll stand
there all [ __ ] day to till they get a
shot so like there's a lot to try out or
something there's a lot of mixture here
that's not necessarily involved in this
conversation particularly like there's a
lot of people who want to be there
obviously and then yeah there's a lot of
people who have been there who get the
[ __ ] under the stick like kaepernick did
i think that's the most common right
they get a [ __ ] in the stick i mean i
mean you know i talked to patrick
muhammed
i don't think he feels like he got the
[ __ ] in the stick
[Music]